une habile
lors d'une soirée il se voit là vous
avez fait une vidéo avec notamment d'une
jeune fille qui serait apparemment
mineur et que vous l'auriez forcer à
vous faire une fellation elle alors
écrit elle aurait pleuré la vidéo de ce
qu'ils nous ont décrite est extrêmement
choquant est vraiment voilà on les
voyait hier tous les deux apparemment
ils auraient vu cette vidéo déjà il à la
question que tout le monde se pose c'est
cette vidéo est ce qu elle existe à
cette vidéo n'existe pas c'est un vidéo
avec ce que vous venez de décrire ça
n'existe pas je n'ai jamais fait ça de
ma vie filmée ou pas filmer évidemment
ça n'existe pas donc aujourd'hui vous
êtes sûr que ça ne sortira pas parce que
si ça existe s'il existe des moments où
ça résulte et moi c'est moi qui ai dit
aux blogueurs parce qu'il ya des
blogueurs qui ont dit on à cette vidéo
il m je leur ai dit sortez cette vidéo
je vous en supplie avant j'aurais dit
sortez la cette vidéo je vous le demande
moi parce qu'elle n'existe pas
ensuite j'ai reçu des pressions un peu
de partout où ils sont allés fouiller
dans ma vie en essayant de sortir
d'autres choses comme il n'y a pas de
vidéo dont il n'y a pas de vidéo il n'y
a pas de victime il n'y a pas de procès
il n'y a pas de plainte parce que la
jeune fille ou là c'est alors juste il
ya une vidéo avec cette jeune fille n'y
a pas de vidéo avec aucune jeune fils je
leur explique qu'il s'est passé vous
avez il ya une jeune fille qui existent
mais peut-être c'est une autre vidéo qui
décrit parce qu'ils ont les clients je
lui expliquer ce qui s'est passé il ya
une 0 vidéo où je fais une agression
sexuelle sur qui que ce soit d'accord il
ya une vidéo à moisn nuit là non il n'y
a pas de vidéo je vous expliquer ce qui
s'est passé j'avais un ancien ami qui
s'appelle sébastien dubois à l'époque
nous dans l'altérité on a souvent on est
on peut on peut se lâcher j'étais fâché
que ces deux personnes et ils voulaient
me nuire très clairement
il allait raconter donc la version que
dit alix elle elle l'a entendu c'est à
dire que lui il allait raconter ça à
nice en disant moi j'ai vu ça sur ille à
gg une vidéo sur ilan en train de faire
c'est en train de faire ça ok il n'a
jamais de montrer il n'a jamais montré
pardon de vidéos où je suis en train
d'agresser une fille alors mineure ou
pas il a neigé c'est parce que hier alix
nous raconter qu'elle était une soue à
la conférence de presse marc élevé donc
je crois que c'est pour lui martine le
soin qu'elle a vu votre pote d'autres
anciens potes maintenant je crois c'est
seb parle plus trop voilà et qui lui a
dit regarde cette vidéo qui lui aurait
montré ses talents vous à la conférence
de presse pas lui décline aujourd'hui
d'éclat en lui montrant la vidéo alors
je vous expliquer ce qu on a beaucoup
parlé s'il ya une vidéo qui a été montré
s'il ya quelque chose qui a été montré
en aucun cas j'étais en train d'agresser
quelqu'un sexuellement
en aucun cas je le dis hein maintenant
est ce qu'il a montré des story de lui
et moi en train de rigoler avec des avec
des jeunes filles je ne joue pas avec je
fis en tout cas moi je vous le dis je ne
sais pas parce que je peux vous dire un
truc ilan je vous dis tout net - alix va
montrer des échanges avec vous ouais
mais tu es un moment voulu dit cette
jeune fille cette jeune fille elle va
très bien je peux même te donner son
numéro tu peux l'a pris parce que c'est
un succès je vous expliquer l'accord
moment donné quand il ya besoin de vous
dire on a une vidéo oui moi même je me
pose la question battant quatre vidéos
qu'est-ce qui vient sur cette vidéo
parce que si tout le monde dit kane
vidéo moi je quelqu'un qui fume pas
qu'ils voient pas je me suis jamais
relier de ma vie donc je suis on va dire
conscient de tout ce que j'ai fait dans
ma vie tiens y'a pas une photo souvenir
peut-être que pas du tout je suis très
je sais ce que je fais